conservatives hate protesting
what a wonderful segue into walkways
rescue america rallies
one of them no no but honestly though uh
you're absolutely right about that which
is part of the reason why we are doing
these rallies right now because
a major adjustment that i had to make
when i did leave the left and come over
to the right
was that very thing it's very very
difficult to motivate people
into action on the right now there are a
couple factors at play though too that
we have to
acknowledge and deal with one there are
much more
older cons more older people are
conservatives than our
liberals and young people have nothing
to live for they don't care you know
it's like i'm 19 years old let's go bash
windows and let's like burn stuff down
who cares go to prison for a long time
right people in their 30s 40s 50s 60s
are kind of like i have some things to
live for i kind of i don't want to
necessarily jump in and do all that
stuff
you know and there's that but there's
also um
they're they're they're more meek
they're they're they're they have a
harder time i think going
out into the streets and standing up for
themselves and what conservatives tell
me all the time and i
i'm really making it a huge part of my
messaging particularly
this year to rally against is they say
well we don't really march we don't
really demonstrate we don't really rally
but we
vote we vote and i'm like well that's
fantastic good i'm glad that you're
voting
but while you're voting the left is
taking over every aspect of our culture
exactly they're taking over academia
they're taking over entertainment
they're taking over the media they're
taking over social media
every aspect of you know and you're
losing your voice
you've pretty much lost your voice but
every single day it's getting worse and
worse and worse and worse
and what i've been telling people and
the reason why i think that
we're having a good amount of success
right now with these rallies that we're
doing in different cities all around the
country
is i say for those of you who don't
understand the the point
of going to a march or going to a rally
or demonstrating think back
less than three months ago if somebody
had told you
i'm gonna run for office am i banging oh
you're good okay
i mean you're probably banging whatever
okay uh if somebody had told you less
than three months ago i'm going to run
for office
and my platform is going to i think it's
really good i think you're really going
to love this my platform is going to be
i'm going to defund the police
i don't want any police i don't want
them to have any money i want to do i
want to do let's just have social
programs and no police
people would do what you just did they
would start laughing right three months
ago yep
three months later we quite literally
have
the the president the uh the
presidential candidate
and any number of democrat candidates
around the country running on a platform
of defunding the police
people are defunding the police let's
let's absolutely clarify this because
they play dirty
dirty games joe biden was asked
specifically
would you be in favor of reallocating
funding from police
you know to outside groups whatever and
joe said yes absolutely
later on he said something contrary
this is a game they play where they're
for both at the same time
yes so they can claim it's not true what
you just said but he was asked for the
request the direct question
yes then they'll they'll say defund
means literally get rid of the police of
course joe biden doesn't want that he
just said to reallocate
then the brookings institute says defund
just means moving reallocating some
funds from the police to other
programs quite literally what he was
asked they're not for
anything correct and except trends
whatever happens
trending you know we didn't used to have
social media so i think it was harder to
gauge the trends back then
i think now they literally go on twitter
and they're like what's our platform
today
oh okay today we're we're against uh
chick-fil-a tomorrow we're gonna be
what what some other papa john's where
he's gone no no more pizza
then they said the pledge of allegiance
at the dnc what is it what is it racist
now
no they literally said oh they said oh
okay i'm like how are you gonna support
all these people
calling for rewriting our history with
the 1619 project
they're they're tearing down statutes of
george washington jefferson hans
christian hag these heroes of the civil
war you'll see ulysses s grant
and then you're like oh but they should
be allowed to do it they're peaceful
protesters
now let's say the pledge of allegiance
it's it's it's the
what's the duplicitous but to the most
absurd degree possible
yes and this is i made a little note
earlier when we were talking because
this is a
another observation that has become
become
crystal clear to me in the last year or
two um
being on the other side having this new
vantage point is that
democrats if you'll notice are allowed
to evolve
we can show you can show footage of
hillary clinton barack obama joe biden
saying that they're against gay marriage
gay people shouldn't be allowed to this
and you know and now when it trended
past 50 percent of of social acceptance
now they've evolved
right but republicans are not allowed to
evolve
if uh if a republican ever did anything
20 30 years ago whatever then that's the
way it is and it's never going to change
and what i don't know
just very quickly what i don't
understand is if you are a gay person or
if you're you know
i'm just saying that as a gay person
wouldn't you want
the republican party to evolve if you're
so scared
of homophobia and you're so scared of
the republican party's hatred
you should want them to evolve but they
won't let them evolve
i mean republicans say all the time we
don't care about this stuff we don't
care
yes you do you're a liar you're just
trying to no
they really don't care anymore at all uh
have you ever watched american dad
yeah so there's this really funny
episode where it's like one of the early
episodes where stan
finds out that i forgot the name of his
neighbors they're gay
and they're republican so he loves them
but then when he finds out they're gay
he freaks out
but then he has a revelation he runs to
the rnc and he says
i realized something these men didn't
choose to be gay
but they did choose to be republicans
yeah and that was one of the funniest
things i was like it's a really good
point it is a good point
uh i i think you look at their
groups like the log cabin republicans
back then when the when the platform was
considered to be
anti-gay yeah even trying to be a part
of a party
that had platform positions against them
allowed them to
you know swing the vote it allowed them
to to you know share the
share certain values and become more
socially liberal yeah so absolutely
in order to make the political party
change you want to be involved
i think it's actually a good argument
for many liberals to actually become
officially republicans because you will
make the republican party
more liberal in the true sense right two
sense
yeah and i don't think see and and that
was part of i guess my point too is that
democrats it seems uh their platform is
based off of whatever is trending at
that moment even if it's 100
contradictory to whatever they believed
last year
or three months ago or whatever whereas
i think the reason why you know
republicans
uh have kind of a pr problem is because
they really they evolve on the things
that i think do matter
like like society at large evolved on
racism society at large evolved on
homophobia and things like that but the
core
values that republicans have don't
change you know they don't
they they they they're about the
constitution they're about the the
sovereignty of our nation and
you know and i don't even think that
that many especially under trump
i don't think that that many
conservatives are about pushing
their religious uh beliefs or or that's
changed a lot
it's became very libertarian yeah i was
actually afraid for a long time
to criticize religion when i was
speaking to republican groups um
because you know i grew up a catholic
and went to catholic school my whole
life so religion was very much a part of
you know the doctrine with which i grew
up and what i learned
um and and that's actually what taught
me to be very much against religion
which i still
am but so i i have no problem i love
that people have faith
even if it's a faith i don't believe in
i think faith is a beautiful thing in
and of itself
you know but it's when you start
grouping with other people and beating
other people with your faith
i think it becomes a big problem like
what the left is doing yeah
they're dogma exactly the cult of
intersectionality
yes the getting people fired from their
jobs demanding they bow putting
now it's and you can see the signs when
they send emails with pronouns and stuff
i understand you want to respect but
that is a sign that you were a part of
this
cult and it's growing beyond just what a
cult is i mean i guess it's not a cult
because there's no
you know dear leader yeah but then what
is it a religion a faith it's
a theistic religion yes it is it's it's
yeah it's a
it's it's a cultish religious i mean
when i
was i mean it's we're already living in
the twilight zone enough with
the masks and then every store that you
walk into
due to covid but you know it's like
they're making these announcements
constantly and you're just like my god
twilight zone twilight zone
but when i was i don't watch sports i
couldn't care less but
i was in a restaurant i was in a
restaurant waiting for my table
and they had a basketball game on and i
saw black lives matter
painted on the basketball court and i
was like this is
literally like a twilight zone like
we're living in a really
scary and it's ever black lives matter
black lives matter black lives matter
blacks i mean pretty soon like
everything is
you know brought to you by black lives
matter i mean yeah you
there was a uh i can't remember who
tweeted this they said their kid turned
on their xbox
and a message popped up saying do you
support like you must support black
lives matter like here's a note about
what it means like press x to accept
yes and a bunch of movies and outlets
after the george floyd incident uh
civics
shows this massive poll support for
black lives matter skyrocketed
and something really interesting
happened over the next few months with
the riots
not being stopped with democratic
politicians supporting them
opposition started to skyrocket so right
now i think it's like 37
opposition for black lives matter and 49
support
really but this is a so it used to be a
year ago
there was more opposition than support
and then over the past year black lives
matter support started to go up
opposition went down
then with george floyd a major drop in
opposition a major increase in support
but then with the riots it slowly
started switching back yeah and that's
why i think
they you know uh they they tried to
blame trump for all the violence
but it was helping him trump sending in
the feds to defend
the courthouse in portland people want
law and order right we have we have a
rasmussen poll showing
50 of people want the police to crack
down on the riots all of a sudden now
they're doing the pledge
joe biden comes out and says oh these
people should be found and arrested
too little too late yes i mean what's
joe biden's trying to steal trump's
platform now build back better
china bad right well you know and we're
we're living in this
bizarre time where uh on a daily basis
we're seeing violence like i never
dreamed we i would ever
see taking place in the streets of this
country and it's not a random incident
this is happening
every single day now yet the left
is hanging on to this narrative of you
know white supremacy and the violence of
the right
i just posted on twitter the other day
thank god for those guys back in 2016
2017 that were holding those torches
because if it wasn't for those like 16
guys the left would have nothing to hang
on to
physically sarcastically they're gonna
clip that one
no no sarcastically i'm saying thank god
for the left
that they have that right because
literally we still have to look at those
images from like 2016 of those like 12
guys with torches
and they're like oh the violence of the
right i'm like i can't even open my
twitter
for five seconds without watching
somebody being having the hell beaten
out of them
or somebody's you know they act like
it's not even happening
i love how they play this false
narrative where it's like
you know uh far right extremists have
been responsible for you know 436
deaths in the past 10 years and antifa
is responsible for zero
i love i love how they just arbitrarily
pick groups and then act like
this is the metric by which they're good
or bad so mine is
antifa is responsible for 7 336
violent assaults and tim poole is
responsible for zero
so you're perfect yes it's it's like
look you can pick any group and any
metric
and and greenpeace is responsible for
zero it's like right
well greenpeace does non-violence of
civil disobedience but
i can compare any group i want to any
group and then choose a random metric to
make something sound good
just because there's extremists who kill
people doesn't mean antifa is good
the rioting from black lives matter over
the past several months killed 30 people
and they act like it's not happening and
joe biden gets up
you see what he did at the dnc he's very
clever
because they're starting to figure out
it's bad for them when they lie about
the very fine people hoax
he played a semantic game he said i want
you to remember all those people
marching in charlottesville with the
torches and the look in their face
and i want you to remember what donald
trump said they were very fine people on
both sides
he skips over a bunch of key contexts of
course so here's one moment
and here's trump saying some words right
i want you to i want you to remember
here's what i want you to do i want you
to think about what those people looked
like and what they were doing
and now i want you to remember what
donald trump said when he tried
chocolate ice cream for the first time
he said
this is great you see it's like it's a
totally random
it's it's like out of context there's
nothing to do anything right
yes trump said that the nazis should be
condemned
totally yes and he said there were some
people that just didn't want to see the
statue come down
right regular people yes he also said
there were troublemakers on the other
side
and some good people too yes so i
tweeted this earlier i'm like if the
very fine people hoax were real
trump was saying antifa was good people
right how come the media doesn't say
that
it's an excellent point it's only the
right wing even though he arguably said
both
he said both sides right trump supported
antifa
right imagine if that was the narrative
no they can't use that though why
is it that when a handful of legitimate
you know white supremacists whatever go
out into public and do something which
again is incredibly rare haven't you we
rarely hear about this
actually happening it's just that
they're really small there's not a lot
of them there's not a lot of them
yeah well but doesn't that kind of fly
in the face of the white supremacy
takeover
narrative of the left do you know what
vox
vox wrote so they write a lot of stuff
something like
it was like you know 20 million
americans hold alt-right views or some
ridiculous
it's like dude i think it was ricky
gervais i'm not sure who said it's okay
to have things in common with really bad
people
just not the really bad things right
he's like he said something really funny
like i enjoy
uh he says he said i'm an atheist and i
actually know i know that's true
he had something like i enjoy vanilla
ice cream and petting my dog just like
hitler right
like that's the joke yeah like those
things are
look you know who else drank water
hitler dead
if we're talking about the kkk the uh
you know
in in the 1920s the kkk's membership
peaked at about four million members in
the
in in the kkk and at that time
the population of america i may screw
this up was either 140 million or about
180 million let's say let's
split the difference 160 million
something like that
so four four million out of you know 100
40 160 million people were in the kkk
today the population in the united
states is 328
million people and there's about
5000 people yeah in the kkk 5 000. so i
i did i've looked over the numbers from
like the adl if you want to be
be kind to that number and expand it to
include
peripheral white supremacy groups the
total number i think is like 12 000.
12 000 people in a country of hundreds
of millions right now to be fair
i don't think antifa is particularly
large either
i'd estimate i probably i'd say their
numbers are probably comparable
however is the media defending and
protecting antifa when they go out and
they beat people yes
and is black lives matter a major
national organization with a top-down
structure that receives massive
donations through act blue
and that has people marching through
streets for 85 days in portland
screaming black lives matter smashing
things
and when looters r romp through chicago
you know a week or two ago
smashing up stores shooting in into
windows trying rob
gucci and then black lives matter
literally came out the next day saying
looting his reparations and we want
these people freed there's a big
difference between what black lives
matter has been doing
with 30 dead throughout the riots and
the white supremacist groups
that are that are fractured that aren't
really you know organizing anything
substantial
you see here's what i try to explain to
people the far right
or whatever that's supposed to mean i
don't think it means anything it's just
what the media says because
if you go to the adl's website they give
you like four definitions of far-right
anti-government
white supremacists that doesn't make
sense but whatever these extremists are
there's a small there's they're few and
far between they're extremely unwell
they're violent
and they commit extreme acts that
capture the news cycle for
for a week plus antifa goes out and does
low tier terror where they beat people
and shake them down threaten them smash
windows look if you went outside
and some dude know who he punched you in
the face it's not going to make cnn
but because they do this every day
dozens of times throughout the country
it's extremely it's extreme pressure put
on regular people and businesses they
know it exists
but the media never covers it because it
never crosses the line
recently there was a dude in portland
you may have seen the video he kicked
that guy in the face yes
that crossed the line all of a sudden it
started to bubble up in the conversation
and what happened
black lives matter i think it was black
lives matter denounced it saying it was
it was discrediting their message
interesting but they try to avoid
crossing the line but still doing enough
damage to make sure
you fall in line right in louis in
louisville
they they're going to downtown
businesses and demanding that they pay
to their approved groups
and when i this this is this is legit
when they went to one guy a cuban guy
cuban immigrant and said pay up or else
he said or else what and they smashed a
flower pot
like they're they're literally mafia i
mean that's what he said that's what he
said yeah
and so this this this all of this stuff
you're watching the tim
show brought to you by black lives
matter no but you're watching the boston
red sox you're watching the nba you're
watching mlb
i don't want to watch that stuff man
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you